all right I think you can get started
now please take a seat so good morning
everybody my name is Julian I'm a tech
evangelist with the WS I've been working
with them for almost three years now and
these days I focus on AI and machine
learning and it's really nice to be back
in Krakow I was here for a code Europe
in December it was cold and dark very
cold and very dark it's very nice to
enjoy the city with sunlight and getting
a chance to visit it's really beautiful
so good to be back so my topic today is
deep learning for developers and well
the title is really important because it
means if you can read and write let's
say 50 lines of Python you can do this
ok so we're gonna start with an
introduction to the underlying concept
some of the theory that actually holds
deep learning together but I'm gonna try
to make it as pragmatic and and concrete
as possible with minimal theory and then
we'll look at some code run some
examples and try to put everything
together ok so you've heard of deep
learning as a subset of machine learning
that uses a technology called neural
networks right so the first thing we
should we should look at and I realize
this is really hard to start with this
slide but hey we gotta understand what
this thing is all about right so stay
with me here we got to understand what a
neuron is and what we're trying to do
really is trying to build some kind of
approximation of a biological neuron so
what we know about biological neurons is
they have inputs they have connections
and if those inputs are stimulated
enough then the neuron will actually
fire it will emit an electrical current
if it's not stimulated enough it won't
fire okay so we're trying to build
something that looks a bit like that so
obviously for a deep learning neuron we
will have input okay and this will be
floating point values we'll see what
those come from and to each of these
inputs
associated a wait which is another
floating-point value and this weight in
a way makes this input more or less
important than others okay and the first
thing that we do when we actually run
something on that neuron is to compute
this multiply and accumulate operation
so we take each input we multiply it by
the corresponding weight and we add
everything together okay
it's called multiply and accumulate so
there you go right deep learning is
really about adding and multiplying
stuff and doing this at very large scale
so if you can add and multiply you
already know 50% but deep learning
really is okay but the problem with this
function is is that it's a linear
function if we change the input right if
the inputs vary linearly then the result
that you value also varies linearly and
that's not what we want because remember
we want something that fires or not okay
so there needs to be some kind of limit
some kind of threshold that says when
does the neuron fire or not so this is
why we add the activation function at
the output of each neuron and over time
a number of functions have been used
these days re Lu is the popular one and
as you can see here it's it's nonlinear
right if if the input value to real ooh
okay so if that you value here is
negative then the neuron will output 0
and if the input to the activation
function is positive then the neuron
will output that same value and it could
be a very very large value okay so this
is really what we want right nothing
happens until a certain point and then
we output a value and this could be a
really large value okay so if the neuron
is stimulated enough it can actually
output very large values and this is
what we want and this is how we
introduce that nonlinear behavior in the
neuron okay so obviously a neuron by
itself doesn't do much they become
interesting when we combine them into
layers and networks and this is probably
the simplest one you could build okay so
we have a name and input layer
we will actually put our data data
samples to predict we have an output
layer where we will read results right
we will read the predictions and in the
middle we have a hidden layer at least
one so in this case just one and as you
can see it's fully connected right so
all neurons are fully connected to the
inputs fully connected to the outputs
okay that's why they're called fully
connected networks okay so let's say we
already trained this thing ok we'll
we'll talk about training in a few
minutes but let's say it's already
trained how would we use it okay so of
course we need data samples and for this
discussion let's say we're trying to
classify pictures okay so we have a
number of pictures let's say animals
right dogs cats elephants tigers
anything that you want and we know what
they are okay so we're gonna take each
image we're going to flatten it into a
vector and we're going to store the
pixel values in a matrix than that okay
so this is the first picture this is the
second picture and so on and so on okay
so each picture has been transformed
into a vector of pixel values okay and
we know what those pictures are okay so
we know for example that the first
picture here is a category 2 and maybe
category 2 are dogs right and we know
the second picture is category 0
maybe that's cats and so on and so on
okay and let's say we have 10 categories
in total so that's the data set okay a
number of pictures that we flattened
into vectors and that we label with
category numbers from 0 to 9 let's say
ok actually we're not we don't like
using this if you already work with
machine learning you know we don't like
categorical values to be handled like
this we use another technique called one
hot encoding okay and that's a
complicated word for simple thing one
heart encoding means instead of using
category numbers you're going to build a
vector of bit okay and again let's say
we have ten categories here so we will
have ten bits and it will flip to one
the bit that corresponds to the right
Gouri okay so if this one is category
two then bit 0 1 2 is flipped okay this
one is category 0 so we fit bit 0 and so
on ok and why is this important because
well this form right is actually much
more expressive than this because here
we can see how many classes we have
first and second we could look at those
numbers as probabilities for each of the
classes ok and what this really says
here is this sample has a hundred
percent chance of being category two and
zero percent chance of being any other
category right we know for sure because
we know what the data set looks like ok
same thing here we know that this last
sample here is category four so it has
100 percent chance of being category 4
and zero percent chance of being
anything else ok and this is this is
actually what we will get on the output
layer when we when we put those samples
on the input layer here right and we run
those multiplies and accumulates and
those activation functions etc what we
will read here in those neurons are the
probabilities for the samples ok so
hopefully if we train our network right
ok we would get to something like this
we take a data sample and as you guessed
we need add many we need as many neurons
in the input layer as we have features
ok so if we have a thousand pixels here
we'll need a thousand neurons here ok
then we run what is called forward
propagation so running that sample
through the model multiply accumulate
activate etc and you read some results
on the output layer and again if you
have ten classes you will need ten
neurons on the output layer ok and you
will read the probabilities for each
class so in a perfect world this is what
we would see right we would really see
zeroes every everywhere except a one in
the neuron that corresponds to the right
class to the right category but nothing
is perfect and it's not going to happen
like that anyway
what we care about is accuracy so being
able to successfully predict the maximum
number of samples okay this is what
we're going to measure around and track
okay so this is where we want to get
but of course initially the network is
not trained okay so all the weights
corresponding to all those connections
here right all those parameters they
have random values so if you take a data
sample and forward propagate you get
something completely wrong on the output
there and it would it would not be
something like this actually it would
not be a one in the wrong place and zero
zeros it would just be random
probabilities for the ten classes okay
because again the network has not been
trained so if we see this neural network
as a function and we take a sample and
compute the output we're not going to
get the right output we're not going to
get the right label the right
probability vector we're gonna get
something different okay let's call it Y
prime one so obviously you need to
measure the difference between what you
expected and what you really got okay
and we do this using a math function
called a loss function and remember that
y 1 and y prime 1 are really vectors
okay probability vectors so it's not as
easy as subtracting one from the other
but you don't have to worry about those
because all the deep learning libraries
provide those loss functions already so
you can just use one that matches your
the problem you're trying to solve ok so
this loss function will give give us the
error okay just a numerical value
measuring the error the distance so to
speak between the two vectors so
actually we're not going to do this
sample by sample ok imagine you have 10
million samples in the data set it takes
too much time to process every single
one and and train on every single one so
we actually train on batches of samples
ok so we're going to take 32 samples for
64 samples at a time run them one by one
through the model and compute the total
error for the batch ok and then we're
gonna make decisions on how to reduce
the error okay more on this in a minute
ok so
keep in keep in your mind we train on
batches of samples not individual
samples okay so in a nutshell the
purpose of the training process is
really only one thing it's to minimize
loss
okay minimize prediction error for the
data set by training over and over right
iteratively and your by by adjusting the
weights gradually during the training
process okay so what we're really trying
to do here is in these examples we I
don't know how many weights we have
maybe let's say 25 or something like
that okay we're trying to find the set
of weights the set of parameters that
give us the highest accuracy for that
data set and that means the lowest
possible error for that data set okay
and we start from random weights and we
have to try to go as close as possible
to that optimal set of weights okay and
that's a difficult problem because you
cannot compute them right it's not
something it's not an equation you can
solve so you have to gradually discover
what those weights should be okay
more on this in a second so the training
process really looks like this we have a
data set like I said we slice it in
batches and again we'll see in the code
that deep learning libraries do this
automatically so no no work needed and
we take one batch okay let's say it's 32
samples and we run each one of our
samples into the network okay and we get
to prediction and we compare the
prediction to the actual result we were
expecting and we compute loss okay and
we do this further back all the batch
samples and we add up all the errors
into the batch error okay so wait now we
have a batch error that tells us you
know what's the what's the mistake how
big is the mistake we made for this
batch okay and now we can take decisions
on how to reduce it and this is done
with an algorithm called back
propagation and so it's a scary one it's
usually that's usually where when people
start looking
and stop studying deep running because
they want to understand back propagation
in detail and it's a bit scary okay so
back propagation as the name implies
we'll go back from the output layer to
the front okay
and layer by layer and neuron by neuron
it's going to adjust the weights in the
direction that we know reduces error
okay so for example here okay
this new wrong the error value that you
get for this neuron depends on three
parameters okay so for these three
parameters you have to figure out if
each of them should be increased or
decreased to two lower error right or
remember these are floating point values
so these are the only two choices that
you have right you can increase them a
bit or decrease them a bit so how do you
know okay re lancelot in a second so
once you've done that here okay you've
update those you've updated those
weights so you can compute the new error
for the next layer and then you do it
again so this the error that you get
here for this individual neuron depends
on one two three four five parameters
okay so once again here you need to make
five individual decisions on increasing
or decreasing those weights and you do
this for every single neuron and then
you move back to the previous layer
until you get to the input okay that's
why it's called back propagation okay so
now that obviously you want to do this
all over again for the next batch right
compute the batch error back propagate
and you do this again and again and
again and again okay until you get to
the end of the data set okay and this is
called an epoch and typically you're
going to train for 50 100 200 and pops
okay so it's really an interactive
process and you train and you predict
again and again and again and again
right computing the batch error and then
adjusting the weights in a direction
that you know will reduce error and and
you do this until you hopefully get to
the right level of accuracy that you
were expecting
okay so that's the big picture okay and
at the end of that process you get to a
trained neural network okay and as you
can see we have a number of parameters
that are really important the batch size
is important if you have very tiny
batches you're back proclick propagate a
lot you take takes a lot of time so yes
you will probably get to the right spot
but it takes too long if you have a very
large batch size then you get less
opportunities to run backpropagation
per epoch so maybe that's a problem too
the learning rate will actually decide
on the size of the updates that you make
to the weight ok we'll we'll talk about
that in a minute
so it's important as well small learning
rate small updates to the weight larger
than rate large update the weights okay
and again too small will be a problem
too large will be a problem and the
number of epochs is how many times you
go through the data set these are called
hyper parameters and if you don't get
them right you will have lots of
problems training okay so that's the big
picture okay it's not really complicated
the only weird thing is yeah I get the
batch size the batch thing and I get the
backpropagation but then you said we
need to adjust the weight the weights
each weight actually in the direction
that we know reduces error how do we
know right how do we know if a given
weight should be increased or decreased
okay let's look at a real example so
imagine you have a function here let's
call it f and it has two parameters okay
and the output is let's call it Z okay
and let's let's say that x and y are
parameters and Z is the error okay and
which we start with random values of x
and y and we want to get we want to
figure out what x and y should be to get
the smallest value of Z okay that's
really what we're trying to do find the
set of parameters that give us the
smallest possible output okay and if we
plot that function let
like it looks like this okay and
remember x and y are initially random so
we're going to start anywhere here okay
so let's say we start here okay
and let's say this is X and this is y
all right so we want to get to the
smallest possible value of Z so probably
that's here right so in a way where you
want to walk down that slope until the
lowest point in the valley right we're
trying to get down to the valley and
remember we cannot compute x and y okay
we have to discover them so how would
you do that right if you were in the
mountain how would you do that imagine
you're in the fog you see nothing and
you have to decide if you you know if
you should go forward or backward and if
you should go left or right okay so what
you would do is maybe you know you would
with your foot you would try in this
direction they say ah yeah okay this is
down all right fine and then you would
go right and say oh no this is up mmm
this is down okay so this is down this
is down so I'm gonna take a small step
here and I'm a little lower than I was
before
okay and you do this again and again and
again and again right and if there's not
a big crack smooth surface like this if
it's friendly you will actually get to
the lowest point iteratively by taking
small steps in the right direction
okay that's the intuition now obviously
deep learning doesn't have intuition
it's it's math so how do you know for
sure that you need to maybe increase X a
bit okay
or actually here it would be if the
origin is here okay x and y actually we
have to decrease x and y a little bit to
go down right initially so how would we
know well remember high school that's
the part you're gonna hate by the way so
get ready to hit it
remember high school right I remember
slopes and remember derivatives right
now all right
are you too kind
well that's exactly what we do here okay
this is a function okay yes it has two
parameters but we can compute the
partial derivative for X and we can
compute the partial derivative from y at
this specific point okay and so that
gives me the slope in the X direction
and that gives me the slope in the Y
direction and then if I have the slope I
know which way is up and which way is
down okay simple so once I know that
well I should decrease X a bit to go
down in the X direction and I should
decrease Y a bit in the Y direction then
fine I'm just gonna do that I'm just
going to need going to modify x and y
just a bit in the right direction and I
get let me stay here okay and I do it
again and again and again and again okay
and this algorithm is called stochastic
gradient descent or SGD it's the
granddaddy of optimizing functions it
dates back to 1951 okay so it's nothing
new it has actually nothing to do with
machine learning it's a it's a master
optimization function and that's the one
that is still heavily used in deep
learning okay so coming back to my
example here this is what actually will
happen during the training process when
you run that propagation okay the
library that you're using will will
compute the derivative for each of those
three weights okay with respect to the
error and then decide they should be
increased or decreased do that and then
move on to the previous layer and do it
again and again and again okay and this
is how you know in which direction all
those weights should be updated and
since we're taking small steps we need
to do it again and again and again
right now this is why we do batch
training and this is why we need many
airports because we take very tiny steps
but we if we take tiny steps always in
the right direction right eventually we
get to the right place okay that's all
there is to it right high school math
nothing to worry about
so obviously surf the surface is not
gonna look like this right will be too
easy it could look like this right or
you could be seeing things like this
where yes you see them to have a nice
global or you know a lower minimum here
and you have you know not as good ones
here so maybe you could start you know
on the mountain here and and walk down
and maybe you could fall in this hole
here or this one right and let's say
this one gives you a higher error than
this one does so it's probably more
desirable to be here than to be here
right and they're called local minima
and another problem could be saddle
points and this one is actually even
worse so it's look it's like a horse
saddle and in this direction right we
can see yes this point here the green
point here is actually the minimum so
fine but in the other direction right
like this this point here is actually a
maximum right and if you remember high
school again you know that the
derivative is is equal to zero
when a point is a minimum or a maximum
okay so if we actually started here and
went down exactly to that green point
we'd be in trouble because derivatives
would be zero we could not update the
weights
okay so saddle points are actually a
problem too so it's a it's a long
lasting debate in the deep learning
community and whether these things are
really exists whether they really are a
problem do they do we really meet them
when in in our daily experiments etc and
this reference article from 2015 says
pretty much yes okay these things exist
okay and keep in mind here we have only
two parameters two dimensions but
state-of-the-art models they can have
millions tens of millions of parameters
okay so you have to try to visualize
this in 10 million dimensions okay if
you can actually do that welcome to
earth
right please solve all our problems okay
so chances are you cannot
and I can't either so that's why
intuition is really important
so yes it's quite likely that we have
weird things like local minima and
saddle points but what Ian Goodfellow
says is yes they're here but they don't
really impede the training process right
we buy some magic we don't quite
understand we actually manage to go
around them or escape them so you know
don't lose too much sleep about those
anyway right
that's the number one question I guess
oh yeah but deep learning is just it's
all crap because of local minima yeah
okay in theory yes there is a problem in
practice it doesn't really bother us
okay if you want to read that one you'll
get more information okay so that's for
the training process right so we do that
again and again and again and how do we
know that we're actually making progress
well we keep part of the data set we
call this the validation data set okay
and it's very typical to do this in
machine learning you split your data set
between training validation and and
periodically so at the end of each epoch
we run the validation data set through
the model in training right each this
usually say in training neural network
not trained because it's not finished
we're still training okay and we measure
the prediction accuracy for this data
set and this gives us a sense of how
well or how bad the network does on
sample on samples that it hasn't seen so
far okay because remember these samples
are different from the training set okay
so we're gonna do that we're gonna see
this at the end of each epoch and
hopefully it goes up showing that not
only is the network learning it's also
learning to predict samples it has never
seen and at the very end once we're done
right once we're completely done with
training we're done tweaking and we want
to compare this model to the previous
models that we trained last month last
year etc we want some kind of benchmark
we're going to use a test data set okay
so a third data set that gives us just
again a benchmark accuracy for that
model okay so it's a very typical way of
doing things three data sets okay so if
we plot all those things it should look
like this so we should see training
accuracy going up really quick and then
plateauing if that's a word and if we
trained long enough we get to 100%
accuracy
okay guaranteed it's if the network is
deep enough large enough if you train
long enough if you have enough data you
always get two hundred percent okay so
the last function the the error right
the prediction error obviously goes down
almost to zero if you plot the
validation accuracy it's possible you
see something like this okay
so again it goes up it tends to follow
the training accuracy and plateaus and
you might get you know a high value here
like a small bump here and then plateaus
again and then it drops and it never
never recovers okay it's quite possible
this is really more you know more
jittery than this it could be like this
right very very jittery but then at some
point it drops and never recovers and
that's extremely bad okay this is called
overfitting it's a the number one
problem in machine learning and what
overfitting really says is you train so
hard on the training set that it's the
only thing you can predict okay so the
model is specialized in predicting the
training data set it cannot do anything
else okay so that's really bad because
obviously in real life you don't want to
predict the training sets you want to
predict real-life samples right and
these will come from you know the
validation accuracy anyway so this means
that when you're training you should
really plot this you should keep an eye
on the training accuracy of course but
you shall also keep an eye on validation
accuracy and and you should plot this
thing at the end of training and decide
which one is the best epoch right which
which version of the network should you
actually use for prediction
okay and you cannot know in advance so
in order to do this what you really do
is save at the end of each epoch you
save the weights right you save the
version of the model at the end of this
epoch and then you plot and you say okay
I train for maybe two hundred bucks but
the best one is actually one hundred and
twenty nine and that's the one I'm using
okay so you have to save the weights all
the weights at the end of each epoch to
know which one you're gonna use in the
end okay so to sum things up deep
running is really about finding a
minimum right you you don't care about
finding the minimum you'll never know if
you found it it's a it's an np-hard
problem so there you go so all you need
to find is a minimum that's good enough
right to give you the accuracy that you
need for your business problem okay if
you if your business problem requires
95% accuracy then fine right do that no
point in in chasing 97% for weeks and
weeks and weeks maybe you'll never get
there so you need to decide what
accuracy you need to solve your business
problem and once you get there good okay
and of course you need to find it fast
because if you were able to find it fast
if you can actually learn quicker then
you trained for shorter periods of time
you can iterate more you can save money
on training etc etc and if you can't
find it reliably if it's not just a
lucky accident if you can find it again
and again and again it's very good
because again you will train many models
you will try many combinations you will
try different data sets you will try
different hyper parameters you will
retrain periodically etc so you need to
be able to hit this accuracy level again
and again and again you just hit it once
and enough trouble hitting it again then
you know it's not it's not a viable
solution so let's look at a first
example
yes that's the one okay I guess that's
large enough so I'm gonna use here I'm
gonna use the deep running library
called Apache onyx net which which is
the favorite library at AWS and we're
going to try to classify a data set
called amnesty which I'm sure you've
seen before it's it's a nice toy data
set it's not good for anything except
experimenting okay so this is a mist
right over there so seventy thousand
digits handwritten digits 0 to 9 and
obviously the game is to learn to
classify those images in the right
category okay and there are black and
white images 28 by 28 pixels so the
first thing I'm going to do is download
the data set that is already split in
training and validation I'm going to
import an X net I want to train for 58
box I'm going to use an iterator to load
the data set from the files okay and the
iterator will slice that data set into
batches automatically for me okay so I
don't have to slice it into pieces and
pass that to the model the iterator does
it automatically for me and then we
build we build the network and this is
almost yeah this is pretty much the one
we saw on the slide except it has two
hidden layers so I've got a first layer
which is the input layer I call it data
I don't need to give it size M X net
will figure it out automatically from
the from the iterator and if you
remember that slide with the fully
connected Network my input layer is flat
okay it needs that it needs a vector
right it needs the data samples should
be vectors so I have to flatten my
images okay so I flatten the image the
images into vectors and then I have a
fully connected layer with 1024 neurons
active I activated
renew and then I'm a second fully
connected layer with 512 neurons
activated by riilu and then I have the
output layer with 10 neurons because
I've got 10 categories right 0 to 9 ok
so those six or seven lines are all I
need to actually define my neural
network again it doesn't matter in which
library you use it you'll find something
similar to this you just stack the
layers like this you connect them and
obviously you never worry about
connecting individual neurons that would
be that would be painful okay so now
I've got a model okay and I've got a
dataset in an iterator and I have a
model so I need to put the two together
this is called binding here
okay so binding the model I just created
to the training iterator and the
validation iterator and then I need to
set an optimizer okay so I could
actually use SGD right here with a
learning rate a fixed learning rate like
this why not but there is a whole bunch
you know I said SGD is a host was the
invented in 1951 so you know more you
know more interesting options have been
invented since specifically algos like a
delta and so on that can actually modify
the learning rate during the training
process right so it does if the slope is
very steep we can speed up and if the
slope is very flat they will actually
slow down and allow you to explore okay
and that's what a demeans with
adaptative okay so they will change the
learning rate during the training
process okay and then I can train so
let's actually run this one okay and we
can see the we can see the training
process going on okay oops
so we see the we see the app box
going by and we see the batches going by
okay and and we see you know we we
actually have a training accuracy that's
that gets to one very quickly because
it's a large network and it over fits
pretty quickly so let you know I've done
this before in the interest of time and
I saved my model here and I get to a
validation accuracy of ninety-eight
point thirteen it trains for a few
minutes but I don't want to waste a few
minutes okay so this is what I get right
I trained 450 airports that fully
connected Network on my data set right
and I get to the validation accuracy of
ninety-eight point thirteen so is this
good is this bad how do you know right
sounds good okay ninety-eight percent
but you will not know until you try
until you try real-life samples so I did
what I had to do
I took my paintbrush application and I I
drew some digits right and you can see
them here and we're gonna try and
predict them using the model that I just
trained so I can load that model again
okay which is pretty much as easy as
this right load checkpoint with the name
of the file storing all the weights okay
and then I can predict my digits okay
predicting one of those images is very
easy you load the PNG file from disk you
turn it into a vector right you flatten
the image into a vector and you push it
through the Train Network
okay there's nothing to be worried about
that's really one line of code okay load
the image put it in a vector push it
through the Train model and then read
the outputs okay so very simple to
predict and when we do that and let me
run those cells again I just want to
make sure I had the right model here
oops there we go run all the cell's okay
and so for each of these pictures we see
a vector of ten probabilities right this
is exactly what we read on the output
layer for the for the neural neural
network okay so we see that zero worked
out okay because actually probability
zero is the highest 99% okay and for the
one probability
one is the highest etc etc so two is
very good three is very good and you
never really see zeros and ones it's
because I stopped at four decimals so
this really means it's at least point
9999 something okay you will always see
non null values here four is fine five
is fine six good seven eight and nine
mmm this should be the highest right
it's not this one is the highest so zero
one two three four okay
so my model is confused it thinks this
is a four okay so that's what I told you
you have to try different samples
you know the validation data set is one
thing but the test data set which should
really be composed of real-life samples
stuff that people will really predict
not just sample data sets this this is
really what tells you how well your
network performs so this is a
disappointing right because I tried ten
and one of them is wrong so why is that
so you could say well this is really a
very ugly nine so yeah you can't expect
the model to predict ugly stuff like
that okay fair enough but some people
write really really bad and digit so you
should still be able to figure it out
but remember what we did to these images
right we flattened them okay so
intuitively doesn't sound like a really
great idea because images are really 2d
objects and we flatten them so we lose
the relationship right the proximity
between some of the pixels and probably
that doesn't help understanding what's
in those pictures so to solve this
a different type of network was was
invented 20 years ago already and
they're called convolutional neural
networks and these networks are the
kings of image processing image
classification okay
and the the basic idea here is whilst
will work with the 2d image or maybe 3d
if it's a color image right it's gonna
be 3d because it's red green blue okay
but anyway we don't flatten anything we
stick to two multi-dimensional objects
and we use two operations we use
convolution and we use pooling also
called subsampling
okay so convolution is actually
extracting features okay here's an
example if you take this filter 3x3 and
you slide it across the image right so
nine pixels by nine pixels going all the
way applying the convolution operation
which is pretty much taking the
underlying pixel here multiplying it by
the corresponding value in the kernel
okay and you do this nine times for the
nine pixels here and you add everything
together and that becomes the new
top-left pixel and then you slide and
you do it again and again and again okay
if you use this filter the specific
values you go from this image to this
image okay
so this is really an edge detector
filter and this what did we achieve here
well we we detected the edges in the
original picture and we threw away
pretty much everything else everything
else is black right we only kept the
edges so we extracted the edge feature
in this image okay and this is what
convolution is about so by running many
different filters okay it could be you
know 20 30 50 filters you extract
different features from the image so it
could be edges it could be contrasts it
could be vertical lines you know or ISM
two lines whatever you know
and you get a combination a new set of
convoluted images which you then shrink
with pooling I'll show you how in a
second and then you do that again okay
and you get your collection of very tiny
images that look nothing like the
original image but they kept the good
stuff they kept the features and the
important information and then you can
flatten this and use a fully connected
Network okay that's the intuition
between behind convolution networks you
automatically extract features using a
collection of filters and then you throw
away you shrink the images you throw
away the useless information in these
pictures and you do that again and again
and again and if you heard that deep
learning extract features automatically
this is it okay this is what people mean
you use kernels or filters to extract
important information and throw away the
rest and obviously we have no idea what
those values should be right here it's
just a it's an example but initially the
values for all the features generating
those pictures are random so they are
learned during the training process so
the training process of a convolutional
neural network is really about finding
which filters extract the right features
to help you understand those images
right and it's the exact same process
back propagation SGD etc etc okay so
gets a little more complicated but the
overall picture is the same okay you'll
learn the filters that lets you extract
the right features okay I'm pulling is
much simpler pooling is just about if we
do a two by two pooling here we just
take two by two pixel blocks and we keep
the brightest right the brightest peaks
of the the highest value okay and if we
do this all over the picture then you
know we get a smaller picture and the
intuition here is that in this image you
don't care about the black stuff okay
you want to throw that away it tells you
nothing
it was filtered out okay what's in
important is really the white pixels the
edge of that weird beast okay so you can
shrink the image by keeping the white
pixels and it will gradually distort the
image obviously but you you keep enough
information to learn to classify them
that's the idea so let's really quickly
try this so we're going to try to
classify the same data set but this time
with the convolution Network and it's
pretty much the one you saw on the slide
right input layer convolution with 32
filters pooling two by two pooling
convolution again with 64 filters
pruning again two by two right so here
from the initial image we built 32 and
then from the 32 we build 64 okay
and then we shrink them so we end up
having a large collection of tiny images
and we flatten everything at the end so
all those tiny images become one big
vector and we use a fully connected
layer to classify them into ten
categories because once again zero to
nine okay so you see this API is quite
simple you can literally look at at the
network and encode it right just stack
the layers and and there you go and the
rest is the same right we bind we train
so I trained again in the interest of
time text again to three minutes and we
get to ninety-nine point 15 accuracy
this time okay so it's a bit higher than
the previous one but now we're you know
we're suspicious so we're gonna we're
gonna try that new model the one that we
saved and we're going to predict again
so 0 1 2 3 you know they all look very
good 6 7 8 what about 9 so is this the
highest now yes it's the highest it's
still not great right which is a tribute
to my ugly 9 here it's still not great
but it's the highest okay so if I had to
decide which thing is this then I would
say okay it's a 9 not super super sure
about it but ok if I have to make a
guess I'll tell you it's a 9 okay and
obviously you could keep tweaking this
to get better results you could add have
more filters more layers etc etc but
again the intuition is really important
ok that's why CNN's worked really well
on on images it's because they keep the
2d or the 3d image and and they don't
flatten stuff ok they just extract
features from the actual image so make
sense that they would be able to
classify them better so you can do all
kinds of crazy stuff for this and
there's a an extra API in MX that called
glue on and specifically glue on CV
which means computer vision that
provides you with a collection of three
trained models okay and these are
state-of-the-art models with hundreds of
layers they've been trained on really
big datasets and and you can do
classification and detection
segmentation right these are just a few
examples and any of those is literally
five lines of code so I'm just going to
show you one but you'll find everything
on github let's look maybe at yeah let's
look at okay classification okay so how
complicated is it to do this so we're
going to call this API to load a
pre-trained model okay so it's called
model Zoo so we fetch a pre trained
model from the web already trained no
training needed we load a local image
we're going to normalize it okay
normalization is important so make sure
the you know the red green and blue
channels etc are normalized and then we
predicted so we take that image push it
to the train model and then we can read
the results and that's it okay
so training your own model is fine and
we could run one of those yeah let's try
okay let's try this one okay let's try
to segment this here we go okay okay so
that's the original picture and I'm
running it on my Mac so no GPU so it
takes a takes a few seconds but here you
take an existing model pre-trained and
and you just get the job done
right so of course you could train that
model on your own data set right there
you go five six seconds no GPU so on a
GPU it would be just like this and this
really takes five lines of code okay so
before you go and try to build
everything from scratch just consider
existing models pre train models that
that might be good enough to do the job
right and you would save an insane
amount of time by using those pre
trained models okay
very last thing I want to talk about is
we looked at fully connected networks
and we looked at convolution networks
okay and if we predict it with those if
we took 100 samples and predicting them
in any order we would still get the same
results okay sequence doesn't matter
which is a problem because when you want
to work with time series when you want
to work with sequences of data the order
of the samples does matter right when
we're translating for example we don't
translate each word independently we
look at the previous words to to
actually get some context so we need
some kind of memory short-term memory on
the past few predictions to make the
right prediction and this is what lsdm
networks are all about so they have a
different type of neuron which i
not explained I don't have time and it's
a little more involved but you just need
to remember that a prediction done by an
LS TM neuron depends on the input and it
depends also on the past few predictions
so they have some kind of memory right
that's why they're called short-term
memory networks and this is very good if
you want to predict sequences right so
time series machine translation Bitcoin
prices anything you want and talking
about machine translation we have an
open source project called Sakai that
you'll find on github that uses an LS TM
architecture to let you train machine
learning models for machine translation
okay and it's super simple to use and
maybe we can do a really quick demo if I
still have a come on
I still have an SSH connection here so I
took a data set for German to English
and know oh yeah slow connection will go
fine okay so I have a few million
sentences in English and in German and
English and I trained a model from
German to English took few hours on a
couple of GPUs so I could take some
German sentences here and I could run
them through that and I have just one
for you here hopefully that works yeah
okay see so if you want to build your
own translation model just go grab Sakai
train for a few hours if you have the
data set it's not complicated it's a
pre-existing architecture and you can
just do it like that okay so you can
build your own translation service just
like that okay
all right I'm out of time so okay I'll
take 30 seconds for the crazy stuff
because I hate not talking about it and
then I'm done so the last type of
architecture I want to talk about is
called ganz generative adversarial
networks and they they are weird
right so who knows who these people are
I know you're working hard but you gotta
watch movies right come on TV if
something no one no one knows nothing to
win but okay I had something to win I
would give it away no that's your last
word okay now you're just very
suspicious now right of this Frenchman
showing you weird stuff okay you're
right to be suspicious because these
people do not exist right they are
generated faces and they're not
copy/paste right so it's not the nose of
Brad Pitt and the ears of Johnny Depp or
something like that it's really
generated pixel-by-pixel by looking at a
large number of images in in the
celebrity data set that's why they end
up being quite good-looking the network
learns to generate similar samples okay
but these are completely fake right
here's another example you remember that
right when you were five year old or if
you have kids you have stuff like this
on your fridge right I'm sure I do
so these are cars right this is the road
these are trees etc and this is called a
semantic map okay and again you can by
training a neural network on images and
the corresponding semantic map you can
then predict this semantic map okay so
you give this to the model and the model
will generate the actual picture okay
and this is HD right now these are HD
pictures so you can zoom in and you can
see a lot of detail actually right these
are really really precise okay so this
and this gun area of research is moving
all the time it's really crazy and and
if you're interested you know I would
suggest you read about that you'll see
some even crazier applications of guns
right generating a new reality all right
so how do you get started with all of
this well I would recommend obviously
taking a look
at the the edibles website where you
will find information on all the tools
and all the libraries that our customers
use to build a pretty cool stuff
okay the blog has some technical
articles etc if you're curious about MX
net and gluon
it's all on github right so just go and
grab the sources grab the tutorials
there's lots of documentation for it and
you can replay a lot of those examples
if you are if you're already doing
machine learning in production and you
have scaling problems right we have a
service called sage maker that lets you
train pretty much anything tensorflow MX
net pi torch sighted learn we have some
built-in algos as well to save you more
time so if you just want to focus on
machine learning and not on
infrastructure I would recommend taking
a look at sage maker we have SDKs and we
have a very very cool integration with
SPARC if you use Park sage make it makes
a lot of sense as well and finally
here's my blog on medium where you'll
find lots of articles on machine
learning deep learning
sage maker and more crazy stuff either
by now I've got quite a collection of
talks on YouTube as well so if you want
to dive deeper on those topics or or
explore what AWS has to offer you'll
find something here and the code that I
used today and much more is available on
Keith's lab so just go and grab that and
you can run these examples and and more
all right okay I'm John thank you very
much if you want to stay in touch thank
you
you